what's going on guys
July 4th is just about upon us that is
Independence Day aka America's birthday
well we got Lady Liberty a pretty sweet
present the most kick-ass America movie
moments ever so crack open a cold one
put some mustard on that hot dog and
shoot a roman candle at your friend
because it's time for
let's start off by going back to the
1980s and the Cold War it was a golden
age of big dumb American pride there was
nothing more evil in the 80s than Russia
and communists everybody fought him high
school kids fought him in Red Dawn
Sylvester Stallone fought them in Rambo
3 and then Stallone fist fought the
embodiment of Russian evil and rocky 4
you know people say the fall of the
Berlin Wall was the end of the Cold War
but any self-respecting American really
knows it was Sylvester Stallone's
post-fight concussion addled speech to
the head of Russia who I believe is
still called Azhar
try to say if I can change and you can
change but if you want the greatest FG
American sports moment of all time it's
Gordon Bombay's band of misfits The
Mighty Ducks against our most hated
international rival Iceland
or maybe I'm crazy but I think the only
reason they picked Iceland as their
hockey rival is because the word ice is
in the name of their country that's how
their train of thought worked let's go
back to one of America's finest moments
World War two it spawned the greatest
generation it also spawned some great
America F yeah moments now Captain
America had a pretty good one punching
the fake Hitler but Quentin Tarantino's
Inglourious Basterds won upsome by
machine-gunning the real Hitler and a
burning movie theater you know when
history is an American enough we'll burn
it shoot it and blow it up till it is
America just like me in high school
here's something with the wrong facts
but the right attitude now if you're not
fired up by this then I wash my hands of
you nothing is over until we decide it
is was it over when the Chinese bombed
Pearl Harbor
hell no German forget it he's rolling is
there anything more American than a
misinformed overweight dude rallying
guys to do something ill-advised I don't
think so
here's two things that are pretty
American the Declaration of Independence
and the president in the United States
what's even more American than that
stealing both of them to get rich can I
steal the Declaration of Independence
I'm gonna kidnap the President of the
United States
if you don't think Nic Cage is Benjamin
Franklin gates is a true American Hero
then you can go back to your comrades
and Iceland oh by the way you know what
else is a national treasure Nic Cage all
right speaking of any Presidente we've
had plenty of badass big-screen
presidents now I don't care if you're a
bleeding-heart liberal or a tea party
Patriot we can all agree that these
dudes deserve a third term
there's Harrison Ford using his
executive powers against Gary Oldman get
off my plane the awesome Terry Crews as
idiocracy x' president Camacho cutting
through all of Washington's red tape
with a machine gun that's what I thought
but the biggest badass in chief ever was
the one who redefined what independence
day even was Bill Paxton dammit bill
Tollman we will not go quietly into the
night we will not finish
[Music]
we're going to live on we're going to
survive today we celebrate our
Independence Day
[Music]
yeah now what was your favorite All
American FBI movie moment let us know in
the comments section below best answer
we are gonna send you a star spangled
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
you for watching have a safe 4th of July
don't blow your fingers off all right
kids
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye Battle of New York you know what
that's talking about Loki Thor the Hulk
yeah that thing and boom
Harlem terror that's talking about the
Hulk not Bill Clinton